how did you get your start because i
didn't even know yeah
it was all a mistake it was all it was
it was the pikachu cosplayer yeah okay
so i i would like grew up with like i
grew up getting bullied [ __ ] for liking
anime and all that stuff
yeah like we all do and now anime is
cool what the hell's up with that
version
but i'm i'm a little bitter um
but like it's it's uh so i i well i was
growing up liking all that stuff and
everything and then my friend uh was
like my birthday and he bought me a
ticket standing at comic-con and he was
like do you want to go to san diego
where year was this uh 2009.
yeah
bro i met uh oh my gosh she's so lovely
nihachu and we were talking about steph
and she goes i was telling her about
everything and she goes oh i was born in
2001 and i was like
wait how old is everybody here
uh
i'm 25. he's the young one he's the
youngest he's 25 i'm 27. i'm 32.
hey
um
yes anyway sorry i got distracted um
go to go to san diego comic-con i look
it up beforehand and uh i see the people
dress up for it and so i was like oh
[ __ ] okay i love pokemon are you going
to do it
he's just dying to crack up
[Music]
into the story
so off camera jessica uh
drank our first white claw which we
bought a crate of this and then nobody's
drunk it at all
uh i only noticed this i was saying a
gun earlier right uh i had a white claw
before and i don't have a great
experience with it but then i just
noticed on the can it says spiked
sparkling water yeah i don't know if the
word spiked is a good marketing word
usually that means like oh [ __ ] someone
spiked my drink like that's going down
so so this is like claiming the word
yeah this is like the drink that i see
everyone in [ __ ] la and california
drink uh 100 calories
oh my god alcoholic water it's it's
alcoholic lacroix fresh i don't even
know what liquor is look you do know
what you do
it's like someone farted in the room
next door and some of that fart got into
your drink somehow in your open glass on
the table
it's really it's like if you got
sparkling water and you sprayed perfume
on it yes all right that's what that's
like it's this is just that with the
whole thing and jessica loves it for
some reason yeah
so i like this when you get
this does not taste good
okay put a little bit of something else
on there
i think it's good
oh it's like essence of mango it's like
a flavor
it's like it's like they have calories
baby it's that it's like they had
sparkling water and they just put a
mango next to it for days
i get it it's a hundred calories yeah
yeah yeah it's no carbs i get that yeah
but it doesn't taste good i would rather
just drink water yeah you know let's
let's just call it what it is it's just
alcoholic water right no one's drinking
no one's drinking this for the taste
because they wouldn't know what it is
alcohol unless you do i do i like the
taste of alcohol which is which one name
which one
you like right now name all alcohol i
like tastes like wine and sake yeah it
depends what type of wine though like
dessert wine
oh no obviously you like your sweet
drinks
you just like sweet drinks a lot of
sugar a lot of sugar yeah i like red
wine
you like red wine yeah
well but like i grew an appreciation
towards red wine and i'd say the past
like three or four years okay yeah i
actually say with sake as well yeah same
with me i grew an appreciation yeah yeah
i'm like i can afford this board is
really depressing when you're broke
because it's it comes in bags and boxes
and you're like
i disagree i disagree though because
like i didn't realize how much cheaper
wine was in europe compared to japan
where it is expensive yeah but in europe
it just tastes so much better and you
can buy something because they make it
there yeah but like as a student you
just want to get far like drunk as fast
as possible so wine just wasn't in your
vocabulary no it was it wasn't australia
we had goon bags which is just like
boxed wine it was [ __ ]
nothing more
how did they form a country
that was like that was like the cheap
like you're a broke college student yeah
it was just goon there is nothing more
depressing than box wine it looks
depressing it wasn't even wine it was
just grape flavored hand sanitizer
so it was so oh so i worked on a
vineyard for a while when i was like 18
in marlborough in new zealand yeah
hello how how did that happen uh my uh
my aunt and i like lived with my aunt
and my uncle down in new zealand for a
while because like we were going back
and forth when i when we moved in
australia yeah yeah yeah yeah your
accent just kind of shifted though oh
dude like my voice is going to be like
yeah because not many people know but
you're originally from what okay so i
was
born in new zealand i was no i was born
in reno oh really so my mom is from new
zealand and my dad is from the states
right and she came over to the states
and met my dad and then she was like
come over to new zealand and then they
like come over and then uh they went
back and forth so they had me and my
older brother in reno and then we moved
and then when i was like so i don't
remember anything about reno but then we
moved to new zealand and they had my
little brother james right and how long
did you live in new zealand for so i
lived there from like three to twelve so
like my entire formative like use of
like who i am is there okay yeah so like
blinky bill all that kind of stuff and
like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you
like so i don't know like what what like
gumby is like when i moved over here i
didn't know have all those like
established american like
right like uh like childhood
shows and everything and it was really
weird so it's oceana things i guess so
did you celebrate the silver no the
jubilee the diamond jubilee like we did
what sorry i'm sorry oh my god
excuse to get drunk and blow [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
so so going back to comic con
the vines um yes so i went to comic-con
and i dressed i looked it up beforehand
and i was like what do people do when
they go to comic-con
uh they dress up so i was like [ __ ] i
love pokemon i'm gonna dress up as like
a sexy pikachu style thing
i went to went to comic-con
that was insane i don't think i've ever
had you like you know those um
those uh cosplay events where they have
like um the girls in japan and they're
like standing there and there's like a
wall of photographers yeah similar
situation with me like way back then so
my introduction to everything was just
hard fast
just
like right off the bat and i had my
actual like full name and everything on
my badge right so like when people took
photos they could just zoom in and they
saw like jessica negri and
you know
and uh so that went like i would say
like viral back in the day for 2009 you
know and then they found me on facebook
oh no yeah like your personal face my
personal facebook and i found my family
and everything and i was like [ __ ] so at
the time i was like i'm gonna make a
facebook page so that i can protect
everybody in my life yeah and redirect
everyone to this thing so it was a
complete fluke i wasn't like some
master like oh now that it's acquired
the internet cloud it's time to focus it
into the facebook page it was like oh
[ __ ] my family make a facebook page and
lock everything down yeah and then
everything just started to just snowball
like crazy and i was just like [ __ ] yeah
because you kind of i remember you kind
of came into existence on the internet
almost overnight yes
it was like really fast i remember i got
interviewed by my founding fathers kasim
g yeah oh yeah i remember that
holy [ __ ] i was going to say that yeah
the first time i saw you was chasm g
yeah philip defranco for me and then and
then i discovered katherine
yeah yeah never forget those are my boys
my dads yeah no so they're the ones that
kind of like
shot it into trade trade trajectory
trajectory there we go and then uh every
year after that me and uh like casting
would be like do you want to do an
interview and then so we would do like
interviews with like california on
comic-con with cassie and stuff and then
started to just do this consistent thing
and i was having a fun time and i was
working at trader joe's in the dollar
store at the same time
and uh i was like i was like [ __ ] man oh
this is getting a little
getting a little crazy i don't know if i
can work at both jobs like while i'm
doing this
i just started to speed run you know
right really cool speed run speed run
you know
she she did a speed runner he's going
fast all right okay yeah
she's the cast
how did you transition like how how long
was it than a hobby for you before it
became a job because it sounds like you
just did like one random cosplay then
everything just exploded all at once so
i've tried my hardest to never look at
it as like and this is going to sound
really cliche and i'm sure everyone says
like oh you never work a day in your
life when you're waiting 80 hours a week
for yourself
but like i tried my hardest to
not look at it as a job and every
costume that i've made or whatever that
wasn't like hired by a company or
something i was like i want this to be
something that i want to do right like i
want to hang out and have fun and like
when i would go do those interviews with
kasim i wanted to have fun and like just
talk to him and be like oh [ __ ] love
castle you know yeah so it would be that
kind of energy going forward and then i
think it was when i did the audition for
the lollipop chainsaw thing yeah oh yeah
yeah
so um they were doing this like back in
2012
literally 10 years ago like a week ago
they were doing this ign search for
juliet starling and a friend of mine was
like bro you should go do this you love
pseudo51 you love no more heroes you
love james gunn you love slither all
those like [ __ ] up movies and stuff
and i was like okay and so then i went
and i made the juliet starling costume
and i went to go interview and i
remember i was interviewing with these
like oh these women were so beautiful
oh my god these women were so pretty and
i was just being like i'm never gonna
get this i'm never gonna [ __ ] get
this and then i remember i did the
interview
and i like i flubbed like i flubbed the
audition like crazy so i keep hitting
you i'm so sorry it's okay it doesn't
pick it up
um i i flipped the interview like
hardcore
and i was like i [ __ ] this
that's fine i had a great time what a
great time you know and then uh i found
out that i had won
which was really [ __ ] cool so was it
a competition or was it yeah so what
they did is they did like a it was like
a search for juliette starling like a
representative of like
this is the person who's most like them
yeah and like because what i what you do
is like you do like this voting thing
and so what i did is i did a photo shoot
and then i would put them on the
facebook page
and then people would vote for me and
stuff or like i think you could vote
like a certain amount of times a day and
so i was like guys go folks i had i got
all my friends piled up in like zombie
costumes and like just stood on top of
them with the chainsaw and was like you
know like did the whole shoot it was it
was really good it was such a good game
as well
such a good game have you played
lollipop chainsaw no
it's really good it's from 2012 though
so go in with that it's it's
an oldie now yeah it's a it's a pseudo51
game and they're all so crazy it was
voting but it was also like judges
decide so yeah so so what we did is they
did the voting for like the broad thing
for a bunch of people across the thing
and then it was like okay and then it
brought you in kind of right right yeah
this is really serious for just a
competition to find someone who looks
like a character it was it was really
extensive yeah i think they wanted
someone to be kind of like
the face but they're also like
professional also like do they still do
stuff like that nowadays i don't know i
don't really hear about it anymore yeah
i think that was like the early days you
know where yeah cosplaying was just
starting to become a thing yeah yeah
like are too worried about people
getting cancelled and stuff you know
maybe companies have shied away from
having like one guy as there oh yeah
i guess it's become like mascots that
have backfired yeah
uh jared from software
i guess as well it's like kind of like
an inclusivity or like exclusivity
problem i guess where it's like oh only
one person is allowed to cosplay this
yeah
yeah i was thinking about that the other
day and i was like that's a really very
uniquely like uh early 2000's kind of
like yeah
like hey girl you want to come
the lollipop chainsaw girl and i was
like yeah you know like
whatever